nur um etwas zu schützen und zwar seien
seine intelligenz sage ich mal weil er
nicht wollte dass irgendwer an die
information kommt gott verpiss dich
hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu lost patt vier heute
wieder am wochenende
und naja die ferien sind schon fast
wieder vorbei das wird alles ein
bisschen geblockt ich weiß nicht warum
und wir waren immer noch damit
beschäftigt ihr die monster verlust bei
uns das hat ihn wie eine komische höhe
von der welt dass man ganz kurz zu bauen
und letztes mal hatte ich glaube ich bei
paris gesprochen ich es dort fand dass
ich euch das allen nur empfehlen konnte
und heute werden wir uns mal noch
weiterhin mit der monster fälle
beschäftigen allerdings wird die heute
fertig gehen denke ich mal bisschen
persönlich komplett fertig gehen sondern
hast du das grobe gerüst sage ich mal
und da habe ich mir wieder ein paar
themen zurechtgelegt die von usern stamm
ich aber die namen nicht aufgeschrieben
sondern einfach nur screenshots von den
kommentaren habe und da vergessen habt
ihn abend zu fotografieren noch ich bin
so blöd von daher
sorry dass eventuell ich euren
kommentaren und nehme allerdings euren
namen nicht erwähne das ist tut mir sehr
leid
nvidia das tier gerade alles geblockt
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt jetzt
geht es ihnen jetzt geht's wieder nicht
mehr so egal wenn wir abbauen und zwar
erstes thema über das wir quatschen
gründen wie viel zeit investierst du
immer so in youtube-videos täglich ist
total unterschiedlich also ich mach das
so aufnehmen und so weiter rändern
karten und so weiter eigentlich mache
nur aufnehmen an den immer am wochenende
nur am wochenende
ich nehme fast nur ausschließlich am
wochenende auf das heißt weiter samstag
sonntag ist wirklich aufnehmen also
nachmittags aufnehmen abends ist dann in
die freunde treffen oder geburtstage
party und so weiter und dies ist
wirklich so was damals habe ich so
gemacht ich habe einzelnen folgen
aufgenommen das war zb bei adventure
maps der fall damit mir tipps von euch
holen konnte habe ich jede folge einzeln
aufgenommen und dann einzeln jeden tag
aufgenommen hochgeladen war dann zum
immer täglich nur seinen opfern von
20-30 minuten fürs aufnehmen unter
normalen stunden für skaten und so
weiter allerdings
war das damit derzeit doof weil ich
nicht so viel im voraus aufnehmen konnte
und als ich dann irgendwann mit urlaub
war war ich schon ganz schön bild naja
dann hat das ganze prinzip auch nichts
gebracht ich höre eine spinne und die
mittlerweile mache ich echt so dass sich
alles am wochenende aufnehmen
das heißt sieht vorstellungen mod
reviews matthäus kann schon lange keine
mehr muss ich mal wieder machen
das nämlich hat alles am wochenende auf
habt ihr die ganzen raw-dateien darum
könnte eventuell etwas tonnen
er habe dann die ganzen raw-dateien hier
so auf meinem pc und in der woche hatte
ich das dann alles an dem tag wo ich
dann noch hochladen und ja das heißt ich
habe am wochenende ungefähr 45 stunden
aufwand für youtube also für aufnehmen
allein los trägt der schöne stunde
ungefähr fürs aufnehmen allein schon
weil ich auch viel aufnahmen da drin ist
wo man sich dann eventuell oft
verhaspelte oder so und ja also das
aufnehmen immer so am wochenende oder
allgemein in der woche für das aufnehmen
bestimmt sechs stunden oder so wenig
sechs stunden vielleicht vier stunden
vier stunden weil man mich muss er der
trays letzter zeit aufnehmen dann fängt
bald auch eine neue adventure net mit
oder die ist schon angefangen glaube ich
sogar schon mit zwar kann ich weiß nicht
wann diese folge online geht und dieses
muss halt alles aufnehmen das sind
relativ viele minuten die ich dann vor
sitzungen eine zocke aber das einzig
wichtige ist wirklich die
nachbearbeitung also da dass es wirklich
so das wichtigste bei displays dass man
dort dann wirklich das ganze wirklich
verpackt weil sonst ist das eine rote wo
man das verspricht bei mir noch keine
musik muss musik hinterlegen animationen
wie facebook oder so die ihr bestimmt
schon irgendwie gesehen habt dann intro
die besten szenen draußen packen
musik auto und so weiter halt alles hat
musste alles mir drehen und naja
jedenfalls ist weil spitzhacke spiel
kaputt ist es halt schon ein immenser
aufwand für youtube allerdings ist der
in der woche bei mir wirklich geringer
gehalten und ich denke auch dass ich mir
ein ganz gutes prinzip zurecht gelegt
habe wie ich das nun allgemeinen regeln
werde
und so ist das dann auch ganz gut
nächste frage mofa oder einfach nur
laufen also es gibt bei mir in der
schule im hofer kann man häufig
führerschein ab 16 machen oder schon mit
15 anfang damit 16 fahren oder irgendwie
so bei mir in der schule und stufe
allgemein sehr sehr viele die mit mofa
rumcruisen und für mich jetzt einfach
nur für mich wirklich zwar lohnen weil
ich selber ich wohne ungefähr vier
kilometer von der schule weg
dabei ist sein mofa wird sich für mich
extrem lohnen
ganz einfach weil ich damit mal zur
schule fahren können und nicht immer
eine halbe stunde auf dem fahrrad sitzen
würde
allerdings finde ich dass sowas von
verschwendungen weil durch das fahrrad
fahren dann bist du einerseits in
bewegung aller einerseits ist bei mir
auch so dass durch fahrradfahren extrem
wach werde
also ich bin sehr sehr wenig ich gehe in
der schulzeit so gegen halb eins ein
wenig da ein schlaf da wirklich nur 56
stunden und ich muss sagen in der schule
bin ich dann oft manchmal also nicht ein
sondern ich bin dann schon extrem müde
aber irgendwie kriegt halt immer so die
kurve und es auch weil alles eigentlich
ganz in ordnung nur durch smartphone
werde ich echt extrem wach weil morgens
am frühstückstisch habe ich keinen bock
auf reden weil ich einfach so extrem
müde bin und ich das fahrrad fahren
finde ich kriegt man da einfach so ein
bisschen weh da müssen wir auf jeden
fall noch mal runter ich finde halt
durch fahrradfahren kriegt man da so ein
bisschen wird man wache auf jeden fall
definitiv bacher so etwa der begriff
ich nehme gleich einfach leitern mit und
geht am herunter so jedenfalls ja also
wenn wenn es sich wirklich lohnt wenn
man ihn wie zum beispiel handball oder
fußball spielt und dieser platz ist fünf
kilometer weit weg und man hat dann
wirklich abends training dann lohnt sich
so eine recht dann will ich mit euch
auch einigen wie zulegen und sein
führerschein machen aber ich finde auch
dass man zwei jahre später oder ein jahr
später ihr den autoführerschein der
klasse b machen kann die richter zur
zeit mache
lohnt sich das nicht so sehr ein
mofa-führerschein deswegen mache ich zum
beispiel nicht
naja aber hat natürlich jeder wieder
andere sehen es ansehens weisen nächste
sache
urknall oder was im moment hatte ich
ganz lesen muss kurz bis heranzoomen
religion oder wissenschaft also
entstehungsgeschichte oder urknall
boah da habe ich übrigens das ist von
zimbo mann 23 eben kurz nase geputzt
also ich bin eine person die relativ
religiös reichlich angezogen würde also
wir sind drei einem jahr in der kirche
vielleicht in zug kommt aber wir sind
halt katholische mein vater hat immer
gesagt so ja gott musste zu beten wenn
du irgendwie in not ist uns und er halt
so was als jetzt nicht so extrem so von
wegen
wir beten top 1000 mal sondern wir sind
wirklich sehr selten in der kirche und
soweit halt so wie jeder andere auch nur
dass mein vater hat damals mit der
entstehungsgeschichte gott und so weiter
deswegen denke ich eher dass es eine
entstehungsgeschichte gab weil durch den
urknall kann es eigentlich nicht sein
dass ich das alles so gebildet hat wie
es zurzeit ist weil irgendwie müssen ja
auch die ganzen dinge irgendwoher kommen
die ganzen samen das ganze die ganze
erde und so weiter also das ganze wasser
das kann ja nicht einfach so von einem
urknall kommen also so finde ich das
natürlich wieder meine meinung also es
gibt auch andere meinungen
und ja nächste sache was wolltest du für
einen beruf ergreifen als ich jünger war
habe ich auch einen namen zwar crafter
trio dann kann euch ist keine frage als
ich jünger war natürlich da gab's also
die ganzen berufen wie zum beispiel
astronaut feuerwehrmann penner und
deswegen wollte ich da manchmal damals
wirklich mal astronaut werden weil ich
die sterne extreme hammer fand extrem
interessant was es dort alles so zu
sehen gibt was man dort alles
zu berücksichtigen hat wie viele sterne
gibt und so weiter also das fand ich
echt immer sehr interessant und ich
wollte damals nicht unbedingt astronaut
werden allerdings wenig dazu bis heute
nicht gekommen dass ich ins weltall
fliegen konnte alles egal
naja jedenfalls will ich zur zeit auf
jeden fall etwas in die richtung medien
machen ich weiß nicht ob ich
medienwissenschaften mediengestaltung
oder medienpädagogik oder was auch immer
es sein wird aber ich habe keinen
spitzhacke mehr kann es sein dass immer
wenn man allerdings kaputt ist es ist
nacht
das frei schön also medienpädagogik ich
hab' ich habe übrigens schon mal darüber
geredet glaube ich was ich hier machen
will kann sein dass gerade an die sonne
geht auf
vorerst hat er nicht direkt in die luft
geflogen ist
hammergeil feilen vogel schön nix
passiert da liegen noch sachen
mittlerweile halt irgendwie
medienpädagogik ich glaub ich hab schon
mal erklärt was das du mir war habe ich
das weiß ich nicht keine ahnung ich sage
mal wieder so ein paar steine brauche
ich noch mehr einfach ein bisschen was
hier verbrennen rhyner
pfeil habe ich nur noch zwei atoll
braucht definitiv mehr falle auf dass
das wäre sonst klettern fackel waren
neue hafke großen bogen kann ich
eigentlich direkt hier lassen weil das
bringt mir eh nix häuser bogen weil wenn
man keine obwohl eventuell kriege ich
viele von ihnen dem werde brauche ich
eigentlich auch nicht definitiv besser
so einer auch kohle auch nicht mehr
ich kann jetzt schon sache machen und 23
und 2 ich könnte mir auch eigentlich
schon neue öfen machen ich brauche zwar
nicht unbedingt gerade welche allerdings
werde ich gerade schon das verbleibende
10 11 danach gehe ich schon darunter
jetzt schnell eine spitzhacke machen
also das sind so die berufe die ich
eigentlich mal gerne ergreifen würde
also die mir auch ganz interessant
vorkommen und dann würde ich sagen
können auch schon direkt nächste fragte
was ist dein lieblingsspieler von circa
0 33 boah ich finde dass christoph maria
herbst definitiv der beste im deutschen
raum ist da gibt es keinen der eben
irgendwie konkurrenz machen kann also
meine meinung bei den themen ist immer
bedenken
das heißt nicht dass ich das sah dass
wenn ich das sage dass das auch eure
meinung sein muss können wir euch eure
meinung in die kommentare schreiben auch
sagen ich würde in meinem voll scheiße
reichlich mehr drüber als wenn ihr
schreibt ja ich bin auch so deiner
meinung weil das kommt mir so ein
bisschen für ziehen mit nach dem motto
na ja also christoph maria herbst mit
seiner kompletten gestik allgemein schon
das ist so extrem kraß wieder das machen
kann und ich finde stromberg ist einfach
so eine rolle die pasta wirklich perfekt
rein wie kein anderer 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
es macht sich doch keine unendliche
lover quelle machen oder
ich weiß gar nicht ob das funktioniert
nicht ob das geht nicht
der werber hammer weil dann könnte ich
die larven aber ich brauche ihn nur
dreimal von daher geht das noch klar
wollten jetzt alleine fahren machen
allerdings hatte ich bisher noch keine
möglichkeit mehr die kommentare an zu
gucken ob ihr geschrieben habe wie man
es bekommt das heißt ich werde einfach
mal gleich ganz kurze um wickie gucken
wie das so funktioniert das überhaupt
noch im wiki nachgucken
moment ich komme ganz kurz minecraft
beta ach jetzt kommen wir diese blöden
zieht so von wegen
die top-5 minecraft sieht wie twitter
das interesse peter alles gar nicht ach
das wieder in der neuesten version how
to find sie kein blabla achter setzen
video ja toll gameplay minecraft
tutorial von schotter 52 okay ist in
einer welt bleibt also der macht so was
okay
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt wirklich so
funktioniert aber ich glaub mir
knochenmehl einfach aufs gras also das
hat der typ nicht gezeigt also mir
während des videos irgendwie ein
gefallen kann man nicht theoretisch mit
knochenmehl auf gras gehen und dann
irgendwie kommt er dann sogar ich keine
ahnung ich weiß es nicht
hoffe ich doch dass es irgendwie so
funktioniert müssen wir gucken ob das
letztendlich auch klar aber erstmal
müssen wir das hier alles wieder fertig
machen und das dauert noch jahre aber
zum glück habe ich viele kommentar
fragen und zwar geht es weiter mit der
kommentar von spec 04 bittet für die
meinung bei alkohol
es ist ein kompliziertes thema horner
kann man lang zu quatschen
wo soll ich den anfang ich fange jetzt
mal mit meinem ersten kontakt zu alkohol
an und zwar war das mit 15 erst
natürlich damals mal so bei der die was
mache ich gerade eigentlich was mache
ich hier für eine scheiße ich bin so ein
vogel
also das war mit 15 da waren wir abends
am strand im urlaub und hatten da dann
so komischen apfelwein oder so das war
total scheiße dateien einfach nur übels
scheiße geschmeckt das recht zu sagen
dann den namen hört eine apfelwein
da denkt man sich schon so wein
apfelwein jedenfalls hab ich glaube das
erst mal richtig alkohol getrunken
also richtig so wir hatten für uns
selber alkohol und unsere eltern wussten
nichts davon wir waren ja so cool
naja jedenfalls so dass so das erste mal
und seitdem gibt es halt wirklich immer
so auf partys alkohol man hat wirklich
immer am wochenende immer zu laufen wenn
man sich trifft und wie fahrzeug bringt
der einen sechser salitos mit oder so
dann trinkt man das leder von sagen wir
bestimmt alle voll das ist total nicht
hatten immer wodka pur und ohne alles
und so ja aber ich find wodka purismus
wenn die alkohol trinken da muss ich mir
auch schmecken ganz einfach ich hab kein
bock denke größe zu trinken das trinke
ich nur wenn ich dann irgendwie besoffen
werden will das
oder mit ein bisschen mehr spaß macht
wenn doch scheiß parties bist oder so
und dann einfach so ein bisschen alkohol
trinkt und dann wird die party gleich
doppelt so gut
naja jedenfalls hat aber auch schon
schlechte erfahrungen mit alkohol wie
zum beispiel nee das ist kein beispiel
das system soll euch eigentlich nicht
interessieren aber eigentlich kann man
sagen dass alkohol nicht gut ist wenn
ihr damit nicht klar kommt also ihr
braucht euch wirklich also was bei mir
man muss echt erst einmal seine grenzen
kennen lernt dass man weiß wenn man
stoppen sollte mit trinken also nicht
stoppen sollte jetzt allgemein betrinken
sondern stoppen an dem abend man sollte
seine grenzen kennen lernen und da muss
man wirklich einmal also so was bei mir
und oft man meinen freunden man muss
wirklich einmal die erfahrung machen
dass man dann rückwärts ist also ich hab
das jetzt verstanden uns damit sagen
wollte dass man rückwärts wieder das ist
was man vorher zu sich genommen hat und
ja einfach mal einer rückwärts essen und
dann hat man ein geschenk seiner
erfahrung damit gemacht weiß ungefähr
okay waren es genug wann macht es keinen
spaß mehr und dann einfach da aufhören
man muss wirklich die grenzen kennen das
ist wirklich das wichtigste bei alkohol
nicht wenn man hacke ist dass man immer
noch mehr trinkt und so weiter weil wenn
man betrunken ist kommt es echt oft dazu
dass man seine umwelt nein damit meine
ich nicht bäume und weiter hat kommt es
oft als du dass man seine umwelt
anrempelt und dann aufmuckt und total
viel grips und mut hat und auch frauen
einfach so an sprechers zwar ganz cool
ist allerdings spricht man dann oft noch
männer an und lässt sich darauf
schlägereien ein und so weiter hat sich
jetzt auch keine erfahrung mit will ich
auch ganz froh darüber
aber habe ich schon oft von gehört dass
da leute wenn sie hatte war nicht total
crazy dinge gemacht haben
also ich muss sagen man muss selber
herausfinden ich habe auch respekt vor
allem die meinen nein ich werde keinen
alkohol trinken finde ich echt extrem
hammer ich finde jetzt eigentlich nicht
so schlimm weil alkohol ist einfach was
ganz normal zu trinken zum beispiel
salitos finde ich schmeckt einfach nur
sowie vorwärts de fanta und so weiter
hat als nur extrem süß mit cocktail
geschmack und ganz viel zucker drin und
dann finde ich einfach extrem lecker
verliert das finde ich einfach das
geilste was es gibt zu trinken oder halt
jetzt so malibu beach oder wodka oder
also alles es geht eigentlich auch noch
ganz gut klar aber ich bin schon wenn
schon sollte alkohol schmecken und wenn
man den wirklich gezwungener maßen
trinkt
nur weil die anderen das auch trinken
das ist allgemein immer so eine sache
nur weil der eine sagt hey komm wir
rauchen braucht man wird sagt auch für
jeden fall nein lacht nein braucht ne
scheiße das ist einfach so vielleicht
wenn ihr so einmal dran zieht oder so
man muss halt seine erfahrung machen
aber wenn man dann einmal machen sondern
märkte ist nichts für mich nicht mit
auch nur weil die anderen sagen ja komm
mach mir das ist total uncool es zeigt
einfach nur die wenig stärke ihr besitzt
also ihr müsst doch einfach mal nein
sagen können und wenn ihr denn das
richtige freunde sind immens auch sagen
okay gut dann nicht und richtige freunde
werden euch das allgemein sagen dass
hiermit auch eure freunde und so was
habe ich auch mitbekommen dass auf einer
party wirklich leute zu den meetings ich
kannte jeder das mädchen noch die leute
weil das personal partie von einem typen
date wirklich die kontrolle über seine
partys sage ich mal
der legt einfach neue leute ein und
macht dann einfach eine party allen
hacke und die kannte ich nicht an da
habe ich gesehen dass die zu ihr meinte
nimmt nochmals diese nähe und dann die
leute herkommen das nicht stimmen da
dieser ein zug und danach hat sie dann
wirklich neues gekotzt aber das ist egal
und das sind als auch geschichten da
könnt ihr zu alle tricks gehen wenn ihr
sowas hören wollt jedenfalls sind die
sachen moment 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 man jedoch
pastorello tracks gehen wenn ihr solche
sauf und lügen wollten geschichten hören
wollt was der typ ein quatsch electric
doch nicht naja egal ist ein anderes
thema
jedenfalls muss ich sagen bildet euch
eure eigene meinung probiert auf jeden
fall aus alkohol ein stück ist nicht
schlimm auch paar flaschen und wenn man
es in regelmäßigen abständen drängt es
ist allgemein nicht schlimm wenn ihr zu
viel nehmen kann es schon mal zu
lebererkrankungen kommen und so weiter
und brechreiz und durchfall und
blähungen und prävention und penis
erkrankungen und
diese hellen erfunden und ich bin geil
und ihr nicht zu der regel so dass wir
das thema alkohol moment nur ganz kurz
weiter die fahren wir schon
marken-discount hat einen
marken-discount etwas gefragt
glaubst du dass roboter irgendwann die
welt regieren werden
hey leute ihr habt so kranke gedanken
wie man den kommentaren es ist echt
richtig geil vor
ich weiß ich für das thema kommt aber
früher oder später denke ich schon weil
irgendwann die menschen aber teilweise
nicht mehr kontrolle über ähnliche
maschinen die sie bauen zum beispiel
sieht man ja immer wieder bei ähnlichen
katastrophen dass dort maschinen die
luft fliegen und alles und das kann ja
auch schon menschen töten und dann wird
es bestimmt auch irgendwann so sein dass
man ihm den prototypen von einem roboter
baut und diesen dann irgendwie falsch
programmiert und irgendwann sind sie
nicht mehr zu stoppen und mehr keine
ahnung also das hat alles mit der
künstlichen intelligenz etwas zu tun
sich intelligenz an alle die es nicht
wissen ist die intelligenz die wir
menschen haben eine art intelligenz
endlich mal und die künstliche
intelligenz ist ganz einfach
ja zum beispiel deshalb die ki das haben
zum beispiel leute aus computerspielen
wie zum beispiel bei fifa sieht man das
gut wenn der ball dort dorthin fliegt
dann läuft er computergesteuerte spieler
auch dorthin und so weiter das ist halt
so die künstliche intelligenz und ich
denke dass die wirklich irgendwann mal
so weit sein sollte dass die künstliche
intelligenz sich selber weiterentwickeln
kann sage ich mal
es gibt ein tolles buch das hat er zwar
nicht so wirklich mit dem thema zu tun
aber das buch an sich lege ich wirklich
zu herzen wenn ihr gerne zockt oder so
lest euch das buch durch es ist so
hammer ich lese eigentlich gar keine
bücher
ich lese komplett keine bücher weil ich
einfach kein interesse daran habe
dadurch lernt man liegt nicht so
wirklich was wenn man eigentlich solche
farben liest oder so man lernt
vielleicht ein bisschen sich
auszudrücken aber das weltgeschehen und
was man wirklich später im leben braucht
darüber lernt ein echt
rein gar nichts also wenn ihr lest ok
schön ich hasse das lesen einfach
scheiße na ja es hat meine meinung so
jedenfalls dieses buch ist einfach so
extrem habe weil ich kann mal ganz kurz
sagen worum es geht ich glaube ich schon
mal werbung für das buch gemacht
nein ich bekomme dafür nix das denken
auch welche abgesetzt so gesagt war
letztens bei max burger gegessen kriegst
du geld von michael peter was denkt ihr
ich hab nur max gesagt und dann denken
sofort alle welt von den max gesagt hast
dich auch geld nicht mehr tage weg ist
hier christen euro bei
nein als ob ich dafür geld bekommen
wetten dass ist nacht es ist nacht ich
könnte mir unten theoretisch eine welt
ich habe kein holz nicht mit seinen
lappen
naja hatte ich mal ganz kurz den abfluss
da kann ich nicht jetzt bot das heißt
ich kann das becken hier schon mal zu
machen
boß heißt das buch heißt es da geht es
darum dass eine person seinen vater
verliert und dieser war computerspiel
entwickler für eine firma und nachher
stellte sich wohl heraus dass dieser
person selbstmord begangen hat nur um
etwas zu schützen und zwar seien seine
intelligenz sage ich mal weil er nicht
wollte dass irgendwer an die information
kommt
verpiss dich du explodiert bokros
gestorben jedenfalls der sohn von diesem
vater also der sohn von dieser person
die sich umgebracht hat ist halt ein
junge namens es war hässlich leute
sondern es ist ein junge namens ach ich
habe den namen vergessen ist so
unwichtig jetzt jedenfalls ist diese
person
ich sag mal schüchtern und zwar läuft
halt durch die schule diese personen und
hat halt nicht so sonderlich viele
freunde und zockt halt sehr viele spiele
im internet so im internet ist diese
person an der king
das hat zwar nichts mit einem buch zu
tun dass lars fröhlich wassers kanal
stimmt aber so großes gehalt geht es
halt darum dass es ein spiel danach
hergibt was sich immer weiter gibt und
dort gibt es aufgaben also ein rpg sage
ich mal
man spielt das zusammen mit anderen
personen und dieses rpg existiert nur an
einer schule bisher seien zwei oder drei
und die leute kennt sich halt alle
untereinander aber die wissen nicht wer
sie im spiel sind
und naja jedenfalls kriegt man in diesem
spiel aufgaben zugeteilt die man
erfüllen muss also von aber das nicht
von ganz normalen von ganz normalen
leuten die halt im spiel sind sondern
also so npcs die evo generiert werden
sondern von einer echten person
und dann fängt dieser typ wirklich an
dieses spiel zu spielen lockt sich ein
der bildschirm schwarz und die person
sagt zu ihm hallo ich sage einfach jason
richardson
peter spielmann namen vornamen seien es
okay ich halte aber nicht jason hat er
dann so ein gegeben dann die person doch
du hast dem blatt wir uns dort und dort
vorher weißt du dass ich weiß halt alles
ich weiß auch was du letztes da und da
gemacht hast und jason so alter krass
das muss weiter spielen er spielt das
spiel weiter macht sich ein avatar usw
und die erste aufgabe die erfüllen muss
um weiter zu kommen und um nicht zu
sterben ist das spiel halt weiterzugeben
an seiner schule an eine andere person
und zwar soll diese person auch willig
sein dieses spiel zu spielen und dann
meinte er halt zu dieser hat er sich
halt einfach das spiel genommen hat es
kopiert und hat es dann einfach irgendwo
hingelegt und meinte dann zu der person
im spiel ihr euch weitergeben und die
person meinte di so ja ich hab das
weitergegeben und derzeit nicht
weitergegeben und der wird dann schon
bis in der höchsten liga sondern so wie
du hast es nicht weitergehen
also warum jetzt hat sich kein neuer
spieler registriert und so weiter blabla
und der kann allerdings so mit dem typen
pc quatschen sage ich mal
und irgendwann also das ziel des spiels
ist ganz einfach es später einen
endkampf gegen einen großen boss und
dort muss man sich für qualifizieren man
kriegt halt die ganzen erfahrungen und
man kann nur am leben bleiben wenn man
halt dieses ganzen aufgaben erfüllt
jedenfalls sei dann das spiel
weitergegeben und so weiter und jede
aufgabe ist dann zum beispiel auch ohne
das paket in dieser und dieser straße ab
der sowieso paket eine andere tante hier
im spiel die hat dort gerade ein paket
platziert und endest du das paket nimmt
es mit und platziert ist an einem
anderen ort und es läuft quasi dann
nachher darauf hinaus dass man aufgaben
im spiel bekommt damit man im spiel
weiter kommt muss man die in dem real
life quasi erledigen sage ich mal
und irgendwann kommt dann wirklich dazu
dass man menschen umbringen muss man
muss menschen fallen stellen
man muss zum beispiel pistolen auch
verstecken so waffen und der bosskampf
wird auch in der realität ausgetragen
und da gibt es dann echt fünf verrückte
spieler die dann fertig sind und wissen
dann wirklich am ende
diesen typen besiegen und dieser typ ist
und das sage ich jetzt nicht
weil das hat schon was mit der story zu
tun das heißt kauft euch einfach mal das
buch
es wird euch auf jeden fall gefallen ich
glaub ich hab die soffin gerade nicht so
erklärt die sehen wie ich das ist aber
so ein ungefähr ist sie und ich hab
selbst war auch ein bisschen langweilig
erklärt aber genau so läuft es ungefähr
ab holt euch einfach das buch
re was also es wollte ich einfach das
buch das ist jetzt nicht hier pflicht
holt euch das und ich bekomme ich fünf
euro vom hersteller oder so nein ich
bekomme dafür rein gar nichts das ist
einfach nur ein bisschen auf das thema
hier gerade bezogen oder keine ahnung
deswegen könnt ihr euch das buch einfach
mal zu legen und einfach mal lesen
schadet auf jeden fall nicht so das
einzige buch was ich wirklich nicht aus
pflicht zur schule gelesen habe also wir
haben darüber zwar schon die klausur
geschrieben aber ich hab's trotzdem
schon als ich hatte und noch nicht in
der schule durchgenommen haben habe ich
schon durchgewesen unterschied das buch
ist einfach so hammer geil
das ist einfach so das ist einfach
richtig hammer also lasst euch das
einfach mal durch und das ist echt
richtig genial und nachdem ich habe
wirklich die suche immer nach einem
spiel was wirklich sowas wirklich auch
umsetzen sondern etwas vernünftigen ki
also nach diesem film haben wir wirklich
mit unserem lehrer auch den film gamer
geguckt dann also die gamer kennen
wissen
der film ist ab 18 und wir waren damals
alle 14 als sie das gelesen haben das
buch und so naja hatte unser lehrer dann
aber auch enthauptet dass man auch ganz
witzig aber wir haben halt uns sehr
lange mit kali und so weiter beschäftigt
und das war dann eigentlich auch ganz
cool also kaufte er ist das buch auf
jeden fall das absolute kaufempfehlung
von mir so was ich nun machen wollte war
ein anderer eingang und zwar ist dieser
eingang mir ein bisschen zu öle geworden
dass eigentlich gerade noch tag und zwar
wollte ich ganz einfach hier so ein glas
eingang machen
der wahrscheinlich direkt mehr
rauskommen wird deswegen werde die stoff
ganze mal hier einfach machen
ich habe ich schon dass die höhe
momentan mache ich das mal hier
hier kann man das mit sich als eine
höhle auch mano was ich nehme einfach
mal lava einmal schon mal mit denen ich
brauche ich noch wasser oder es waren
also erebos ist echt sondern sein buch
holt es euch ganz einfach so schnell
wieder raus hier so wo kann ich ja jetzt
den blick nach oben bauen
ich brauche jetzt einfach hier
genau hier so und zwar geht ihr dann
leiter her dann mache ich das glas jetzt
gleich kommt bestimmt in die sand
runtergefallen moment welche koordinate
ist das aber wenn ich auf 3 3 seht ihr
dienst ead das ist scheiße
egal wie toll das jetzt fast gestorben
macht kein ding ja okay gut
scheiße hier war es okay gut
hier brauche ich nicht so da wollte ich
lasse ich auch nicht
im moment an jedoch hier wollte ich ja
so ok gutherzig geklappt okay da bin ich
wieder hier weil ich jetzt nämlich
leitern leitern dran machen und dann
kann man hier dann halt so runter also
jeder nicht sondern hier so und da muss
ich mir da erstmal leitern holen damit
ich einen anderen ausweg als den hier
weil der ist echt extrem heikel aber ich
brauche erstmal holz dafür von holz habe
ich nicht allzu viel arbeit also letztes
thema war glaubte dass roboter die welt
regieren
das sind themen die ich eigentlich für
die today show ausgesucht habe aber die
kann ich als auch einfach mal benutzen
zwar hat der gleiche typ also
marken-discount wieder gefragt glaubt
ihr auch dass 2012 die welt untergehen
ein die wird nicht untergehen das kann
ich euch versprechen das kann ich sein
es wurde schon zehn milliarden mal der
weltuntergang angekündigt von
verschiedenen leuten aus verschiedenen
regionen und ländern
die einfach nur geld und aufmerksamkeit
dadurch haben wollen und das ist genauso
als waren letzte single hat gerüchte
verbreitet dass hardy nicht mehr weil
pete war und dann hat dieser tipp
aufmerksamkeit eines geglaubt und so
genau ist das auch blöder vergleich
jetzt aber es stimmt und jedenfalls ist
es kann nicht sein dass 2012 die welt
untergehen weil dann die stars nichts
besonders
nur dass der kalender von diesen doofen
mayas da zu ende geht und die uns jetzt
alle angst machen wollen so von wegen
kein länder geht zu ende das heißt ihr
werdet alle sterben denke mir auch so
alter jeder der das glaubt ist irgendwie
doof
sorry aber das ist einfach so weil nur
weil er den song komischer kalender dazu
energie heißt es nicht leicht das bei
uns allen in die welt untergeht das
heißt höchstens dass die eventuell neuen
kalender anfangen müssen weil wir müssen
das papier auf treiben wir werden alle
sterben
ich find's einfach so unglücklich dass
david darauf darum geht wieder so ein
ibiza halt gemacht einfach nur wegen
diesem film in diesem film 2012 wenn die
nicht kennt einfach mal angucken das ist
auch übelste so von dingen der kalender
der maya geht zu ende und angela merkel
und barack obama und alle die haben
schon arche noahs hier gemacht und so
damit alle menschen gerettet werden
können und alle wichtigen menschen und
so schrecklich der film an sich zwar gut
gemacht aber die wahrheit hinter diesem
film ist einfach nur totaler bullshit
es ist einfach so ach das ist ja die
treppe dann mache ich das mal ganz kurz
aus komplett koppel stone
welche direkt runter gehen ich weiß gar
nicht wie wir untergehen
also ich denke dass ich die neue stück
so bis hier ungefähr das sollte ungefähr
passen also dann ich da unten immerhin
und kindern die monster die dann
wiederum von dieser etage wo ich jetzt
daran vorbei bin dort runter gefallen
sind und dort unten dann elendig
verrecken
da steht jetzt eine fackel sind gleich
wieder vorbei also nicht die folge
sondern die nacht für die dieser tage
ist vorbei egal ihr wissen was meinem
penis so der hund schüttelt mit dem kopf
du so geht das nicht sogar hatte ich
habe ich noch reisen das eigentlich
kommen stimmt ich wollte noch neue
spitzhacken machen
ich werde auch noch irgendwas machen
neuer eimer brauche ich erstmal nicht
ach so ich brauche leitern stimmt man
kann glaube ich in dieser version auch
nur alle zwei blöcken leiter platzieren
oder also ich glaube das geht noch oder
ich muss einfach nicht gucken
llambi 46 ach du scheiße das viel egal
jetzt ein paar sachen hier einlagern so
und so eine neue schaukel kann ich mir
übrigens auch noch machen fällt mir grad
so auf infos penan nach und zwischenahn
neues thema erzählen sie das letzte
findet ihr youtube oder fernsehen besser
von 10 0 mit gute frage also zur zeit
muss ich sagen ich guck mehr youtube als
fernsehen aber ich gucke auch mehr
fernsehen als frühjahr muss ich wiederum
da sagen ist jetzt für euch
wahrscheinlich unverständlich aber ich
habe damals wirklich fast gar kein
fernsehen geguckt warum hat er gar kein
fernsehen guckt ganz einfach es hat mich
nie interessiert was dort gelaufen ist
es war einfach nur kaffee sind bei
youtube kann man sich selber zeiten
aussuchen wann man was gucken will und
so das ist halt so ganz gut diese dass
man der variabel ist wenn man irgendwas
gucken will und jetzt nicht so nach dem
motto ja ich muss jetzt ganz schnell
nach hause weil dann öffne serie im
fernsehen und nicht auf ihr nicht
verpassen und bei youtube gibt es dieses
wort verpassen gar nicht geht einfach
nicht man kriegt immer alles irgendwie
mit wenn man will
und na ja im moment finde ich halt ganz
cool bei youtube damals richtig scheiße
richtig doofe idee und ich mach das mal
so
wie machen das jetzt ich habe auch keine
comics regal
ich werde das schon hinkriegen also
allgemein würde ich erst mal sagen finde
ich youtube zurzeit werde aber auch
dadurch dass ich jetzt das jetzt
natürlich die bundesligasaison wieder
angefangen hat willi natürlich ging es
auch ganz gut hier fernsehen
naja ich weiß ich kann mich nicht so
genau entscheiden aber ich denke auf
dauer wird youtube irgendwann besser
sein als fernsehen
übrigens müssen unsere bruder auch mal
noch ein bisschen besser gestalten hier
kann er nicht weiter zu gehen ihr können
nicht weiter zu gehen ist dann will ich
sagen warum es einfach so ein riesen
koloss und dann auch noch um diesen
eingang hier um sich und die ecke aber
aus cobblestone ist muss sich schön
aussehen sondern es muss stabil sein
gegen blitze und so weiter das heißt ich
werde das jetzt erstmal eingrenzen so
ein bisschen so euch den kommunisten
blöde frage ob ich komm ist toll alles
voll
so also wir brauchen auf jeden fall ein
bisschen schön sortiert
ich wollte hier so ein eckhaus rum bauen
ich weiß zwar noch nicht ganz genau wie
das aussehen wird es wird wahrscheinlich
sehr kaka aussehen aber ich muss einfach
mal darum ihr braucht jetzt auch gar
nicht sehen kannst überhaupt nicht bauen
ich weiß da brauchte ich noch in die
kommentare schreiben
aber ich will mich damit auch nicht so
beschäftigen denn ich bin minecraft nur
so fällt es mir spaß macht und nicht
weil ich es irgendwie mir was beweisen
will und euch dass ich ja so supertoll
bauen kann natürlich einfach nur weiß
nicht wie weit gehe ich hier noch um
noch mal so
ein riesiges haus nachher denkt euch
wahrscheinlich gerade in afrika bestimmt
naja sind doch schon da beide welt 40
minuten befasst da hinten seegras nicu
und ich habe daran gedacht und später
seine farben noch ingo zu bauen
allerdings fällt auf ich muss das erst
gar nicht aus koppl stone ich das jetzt
einfach so und zwar geht ja hier in
einer später 150 eine farm mit einfach
nur fackeln oder das bonner schon tiere
weil bei den neuesten version ist ja so
wenn man tiere farben will dann braucht
man weizen damit man irgendwie anlockt
oder so aber neuer also was für
neuerdings also hier in dieser version
musik wirklich einmal eine fackel
clinton
und dann kommen da schon ganze tiere
angeht dackel wollen unbedingt diese
fackel im unternehmen und wollen fackel
rutschen
aber das wollen wir ja genau so
ich habe es noch gar kein thema mehr
bewegt alle themen schon fest vergeben
sind und so ihr könnt mir übrigens auch
themen die kommentare schreiben
ich werde euch anhand vom namen wartet
kann ich mal ganz kurz löschen hier
ich werde euch anhand vom namen dann
nennen so wie jetzt gerade nur ich werde
euch halt nicht einblenden weil das echt
extrem viel arbeit ist damit allgemein
schon 40 minuten video rind und wenn ich
da noch bilder einpacken denn dort hat
noch mal eine stunde länger und beim pc
ist einfach nur total scheiße das
solltet ihr wissen
von daher ja ich werde bald einen neuen
kaufen naja jedenfalls
also deswegen einfach etwas nicolas
schreiben und ich werde euch dann
erwähnen und euer thema gleich bank
misshandeln wollte schon sagen behandeln
der baum hier kommt weg so hier kommt
noch nachts wird doch nicht einfach nur
die sonne untermauern kann sein dass er
oder stoppen so ich weiß auch gar nicht
wie das irgendwie mit weil es gab eine
schnapsidee ganz spontan war dass ich
mir einfach mal so klingen aber ich
glaube ich habe da schon eine idee
jetzt hat eine gute idee aber dafür dass
wir müssen ein bisschen größer bauen
kann ich brauche unbedingt sondern von
diamanten damit besser als die stände
abgekommen oder ich packe neben dem
ultimate nordrhein
aber ich glaube weil ich weiß gar nicht
ob der für diese version noch existiert
welche mit kristen scott das werden sich
mit ganz vielen die hand nehmen kraft im
table soll eine faust machen kann
mit dem angeblich wie in creative award
einmal drauf drücken der steines weg
also was könnte eventuell machen oder
dass ich einfach irgendwann wenn jemand
fünf jahren den opfern damit creative
monte crostis abfälle aber ich würde
sagen dass es erstmals frei per hand
machen
und ja übrigens habe ich auch mal fragen
bekommen dann geht eigentlich los weil
viele meinten ja das ist schon
abgebrochen sei noch zwei folgen jetzt
natürlich auch chancen
bis ich hab keine zeit dass der zweiten
appell an euch alle alle die jetzt lust
immer noch jetzt gerade gucken und total
begeistert hiervon sind nur wenn jetzt
vielleicht mal ein wochenende keine
serie kommt es also keine folge heißt
dass nicht gleich dass ich gestorben bin
dass lost vorbei ist dass es abgebrochen
ist wir kommen so leute an du [ __ ]
wieso machst du nicht lust weiter willst
du schon wieder alles abbrechen erwartet
einfach mal ab oder guckt bei facebook
so das war der plan euch cook bei
facebook wenn es etwas nicht gibt eine
folge die sonst immer kommt oder wie zum
beispiel die götter schau alle zwei tage
wenn ich das nicht schaffe ich poste es
immer bei facebook guckt dann einfach
bei der seite vorbei wenn die folge
nicht kommt die ihr sehen wollt
das ist ganz einfach ganz einfach
sagen wir einfach bei facebook like
drücken und dann wird immer auf dem
neuesten stand oder einfach vorbei
kommen das können sogar die leute die
kenntnis zu haben das heißt ich habe
keinen facebook soll jetzt keine ausrede
man kann auch gleich die post angucken
ohne dass man facebook wirklich sich da
angemeldet hat und ja deswegen erwartet
da immer genauestens ob jetzt ein video
kommt oder nicht beruhigt habe ich mich
jetzt nicht so einfach dann bei facebook
in der stadt oder auch die leute die es
dann bei facebook gelesen haben ich hab
das er geschrieben und irgendwie da
steht er damit viele leute man damit
erreicht hat und dann bestimmt
vor 4000 5000 leute hab ich damit
erreicht rannte nicht einfach so
hinnehmen sondern dann vielleicht auch
die anderen unter dem die wir uns
darüber informieren wenn die kommentare
sie wann kommt lasst einfach schreiben
ja jetzt bei facebook gepostet dies und
dies und jetzt bitte sei dadurch und
irgendwie sowas halt damit die leute
wissen dass es nicht abgemacht ist so
dass ich nicht gestorben sondern ist
einfach nur eine kleine pause ist
rechtzeitig geschafft habe ganz einfach
danke an allerdings machen übrigens
mächtig ein richtig fettes lob an euch
aussprechen 2 letzter zeit die
bewertungen sind ob die kommentare sind
top macht mir sehr viel spaß und so was
das sein und so macht das auch richtig
spaß bei youtube so muss das sein vater
spaß und das finde ich einfach extrem
geil dass jeder einfach so mit spaß
dabei seid des neuen konzepts angenommen
habe glaube ich ja schon seinen dank
herr video gemacht und da wollte ich
mich ein halber bei euch bedanken
also danke an euch meine super tolle
community ich habe euch alle ganz doll
lieb und dicken schmatzer von mir auf
alle eure minder ich würde auch sagen
sie mal zum familienstück das wird
wieder ein zu langsames die folge
also das wird nicht so lange schon eine
stolze landshut lag
der im so viel sand nach einer weg uns
richtig viel glas machen ich weiß nicht
genau wie viel glas machen will ich
erstmal was sich allgemeinen dachte ja
das werde hier noch in dieser folge kurz
sehen und zwar habe ich dass er jetzt so
ein bisschen ausgebreitet ich wollte
hier alles voll mit im moment warte ich
kann ich das niveau zeigen hier so alles
gebäude halt moment und dann halt hier
so wieder zurück und hier recht zeit so
alles immer gebäude und so weiter mit
ganz vielen kisten und dann auch hier um
die ecke quasi sonnenhaus wie ein l wie
ein umgedrehtes l
dann ist das hier so alles haus dass da
so dass hier und damit ist dann so ein
innenhof wo wir dann tiere und farmen
und so weiter haben
also ich denke das könnte eventuell
jeden fall ganz neues aussehen
allerdings würde ich sagen dass ich
jetzt erst mal kurz den stopp machte es
wird nacht und ich würde sagen bewertet
das video mit einem daumen hoch wenn es
euch gefallen hat mit einem daumen
runter wenn es euch nicht gefallen daran
sehe ich ob ihr mehr von dem volt und ob
es euch gefällt und bis zum nächsten mal
teams